mais que fait grand mercal joëlle
ecormier nathalie millet chez océan
jeunesse elle vérifie chaque matin dans
son miroir que tout va bien
vieux rouge ongles crochus dans noir
poil sur le nez vilains boutons
elle essaie de démêler ses cheveux elle
a déjà cassé 107 peigne elle se fabrique
une perruque avec les cheveux de pélé
que crache le volcan ça lui fait une
tête d'ours inde et colorée elle ne sait
pas quoi mettre la robe noire ou la robe
noire elle trouve que sa garde-robe et
triste
elle nettoie sa case avec un balai de
brand elle se met à rire très fort comme
une vieille sorcière méchante comme ça
pour rien juste pour s'entraîner à l
ramon les cheminées du volcan elle fait
cuire un civet tempe sur un tout petit
volcan dans une marmite bien noir elle
trouve qu'il fait trop chaud près de la
fournaise et va prendre l'air elle fait
la course avec les papangues un call à
califourchon sur son bébé tout elle rêve
d'un pays où il fait froid avec de la
neige
à force de rêver elle brûle son site
étant alors ça m'énerve et elle tape des
pieds comme un marmaille
ça réveille le volcan elles regrettent
le temps lontan
quand tout le monde avait peur d'elle
boom parfois elle se sent un peu seul
alors elle colle son oreille par terre
pour écouter ce qu'on dit chute ne parle
pas trop fort elle en a assez qu'on lui
demande l'heure toutes les heures
grand-mère calquer leur île et il n'y a
pas marqué de pendule sur son front
parfois elle est d'accord pour jouer à
l'horloge parlante et comptent les
heures jusqu'à minuit et après elle a
sommeil et vasco chez elle se dit
qu'elle aimerait bien souks et une
petite fille ou un petit garçon pour lui
faire la conversation
elle est triste parce qu'elle pense à
son enfant qu'elle n'a pas pu guérir
elle aimerait bien aller à la plage mais
elle n'a pas de maillot de bain
elle aime faire griller des saucisses au
dessus de la lave
mais elle n'a personne a invité l aime
bien quand il pleut qu'il y à du gros
brouillard et qu'elle joue aux dominos
bien au chaud chez z
elle mange des gros poids et après elle
pète au lit ça pue le soufre elle dit
que c'est le volcan
elle n'aime pas qu'on raconte ses
histoires juste quand c'est halloween
d'ailleurs avant ça n'existait pas
halloween elles s'offrent un super feu
d'artifice gratuit tous les 14 juillet
et parfois elle ses peurs